so this is the last Talk of the day and
I have formal semantics in the title so
let's see how this goes I'm going to try
my best all right I I believe that I can
get this all across um okay so I'm going
to talk about uh this paper from 2007
which is about how to give semantics to
multilanguage programs um and this is
one of my favorite papers and by the
time you get to the end you'll sort of
get a sense of why um so there are a lot
of different languages in the world
and any realistic language is going to
support some form of interoperability
and over the years you know decades um
interoperability has come in many
different shapes and forms uh
implemented in different ways right
there's um almost every single language
supports of cffi usually using some sort
of swigg uh you know tooling to generate
wrappers um we have other kinds of you
know like specialized o camel C types
inline C for hll there's the Java jni
rust bingen right we're all familiar
with these tools because we all need to
sort of reach for language interrup at
one point or another um then there's
also um you know interrup between
languages that Target the same um IR so
for instance languages that Target the
jvm or languages uh that uh you know
supporting interrupt between net
languages that Target the Cil so just
all sorts of different flavors right
there has been so much work over the
years on supporting language interrupt
in in realistic fashion in in order to
make lives easier for
developers now let's talk about the
paper that I want to talk about um so
this paper pole 2007 operational
semantics for multilanguage programs
basically what they observed is that
there had been a lot of work on language
interoperability until then that but
mostly um all of that work especially
research um and development of course um
existing work almost exclusively focused
on how to implement interop efficiently
it was always always about how do we
make this faster um maybe not always
always but almost always about how do we
make it faster the net effort and so on
of course there was a Cil a Java bite
code is typed um so so that gets you
closer to safety but there wasn't much
emphasis on how do we understand the
semantics of interoperating programs at
the source level right nobody ever
really kind of wrote that down um it's
and the source level is where the
programmer is operating right so how
does a programmer understand what's
actually happening in terms of behavior
when two Source programs interact right
this is um and and how do researchers
understand it frankly because if if
researchers can't understand it then
they can't extend it properly and so on
and build on it or verify it um so the
central contribution of this paper is
basically to give a mechanics a recipe
of how to take two existing languages
and put them together in a very nice
simple uniform kind of way and you know
in a way that in the years that have
followed has been something that other
people were able to pick up and and
apply to other more challenging um case
studies of languages that's that's why I
love this paper um and it demonstrates
actually even in this very small kind of
paper it demonstrates that even for a
pair of very simple languages I'll show
you the languages in just a second um
you can make very different
interoperability design decisions like
there's there's such a vast space um and
some of it you know looks like existing
language some of it doesn't there really
is a spectrum so we'll talk about some
of that as we go on all right so what I
would really like to do is give you a
flavor of how those mechanics work I'm
going to show you formalism all right
and show you how we're going to take two
languages and put them together um I'll
keep it simple but all right so here's
the basic recipe um you have two
languages a blue language and a red
language um for on this slide only I'm
just going to call them languages A and
B and the basic idea is you take the
entire language but then you add
boundary forms to it now what this is
doing is it's letting my um blue
language terms my language B terms I can
put them under an AB boundary so that um
e can be used in an a language a b
language term can be used in an a
language context and vice versa the red
uh term from the a language can be used
in a b language context and I've put
Types on both sides to just tell you you
know the the basic gist of uh what they
had in mind even though they weren't
putting blue and exactly blue and red
Types on the two sides uh because of
their choice of languages but that's the
basic idea something that's typed in one
language what type should it have in the
other one that's what those types on the
boundaries are indicating because that's
an issue of safety and then they
basically you know say Define the
semantics of boundary terms I'll show
you an example of uh sorry typing rules
for boundary terms I'll show you uh how
in a second and then the last bit I
think is the most Central one that I
want to focus on the idea that that they
have put forward is when you have a blue
term under a boundary so sitting in a
red language context just just run the
blue term until you get a blue value
using the blue languages semantics and
then this is where you do the
interesting work the part that's in The
Orange Box figure out how you're going
to take that blue value and convert it
to a red one okay and for the other
boundary figure out how you're going to
convert the red value to a blue one
that's where you the language designer
who's designing the interrupt is making
all of their real decisions okay
otherwise just run it until it gets to a
value now before I go on I'm just going
to say this one thing there's a note in
the paper where they say our recipe
should be applicable to really any
language that has Expressions that when
you run them produce values and you can
see that right there in the in the boxes
right if my blue language gives me a
value I will convert it to a value in
the other language I'll come back to
this towards the end because it's not
obvious how to do that if your language
is really low level and doesn't quite
produce values okay um and then you know
once you have a full multil language
they just use completely standard
techniques to prove type soundness so
you know it it for the first time this
technique kind of makes uh proving types
sound of language interoperating
languages is
possible okay so let me show you what's
actually in the paper so they had a
language which the red one which they
called ml uh but it's actually just a
simple very very simple typed Lambda
calculus typed language typed functional
language um and then they had a language
called scheme uh which is an untyped
Lambda calculus essentially um it's
scheme like because it has some
predicates you can do procon NATA um the
variables for ML are red the variables
for scheme are blue all right so just
take your two languages don't even think
about it you have a formal spec for them
just take them um then this slide's
going to be a little scary but there's
nothing unusual here just take all the
typing rules and all the operational
semantics that you already have defined
for those languages and assume that you
have them don't read them assume that
you have them the only interesting thing
I want to point out on this slide is
they have this type called TST for the
scheme type because in scheme nothing
has a type so we're going to give it one
single type called the scheme type
that's it okay all
right now for the interesting part take
uh take your syntax and add those
boundaries so s is for scheme M is for
ML and uh MSE is allowing us to put this
blue scheme term on the inside in an ml
context and on the ml side we put the
type because the type on the scheme side
is boring it's always going to be the
scheme type right so we're not going to
annotate it it's always going to be that
and vice versa for the other boundary
the SM boundary which lets us put ml
terms inside scheme
code now we have to make some decisions
we basically have to decide that when
these boundaries you know like what are
these what sort of interop are these
boundaries enabling and I'm going to
show you two flavors of this this first
one is something they call the lump
embedding which does the following
basically if you're familiar with like
hascal stable pointers it allows you to
take values from one language and pass
them over to the other one as a lump but
the other language can't do anything
with them if if you if it wants anything
done with them it has to pass them back
to the first language and and that's
where you you get to use your values so
it's the lump embedding you pass lumps
across the boundary your the other
language is never able to really you
know do anything with them other than
pass them back okay so the mechanics of
this is now we have to decide that the
values that go across the boundary have
this shape you know l msv v that is
wrapped in a lump boundary and SM to V
which is essentially going to be a ml
value wrapped in a scheme boundary but
it's going to remain as a as a lump
essentially when we carry it around on
the other side
um
okay now we're going to add our boundary
typing rules and they're really simple
it just says if blue e has a has a valid
scheme type then you can put it under an
MS boundary and it has the red it should
have uh it has the red type towel uh
that's you know sitting on the boundary
um and for um the other boundary we say
that if e is an ml term with type towel
then you can stick it under a boundary
and put the type towel annotation on it
and you get a scheme type an expression
anme expression of the scheme type right
so whatever's underneath has that type
the other side has the type indicated by
that side of the
boundary okay and that's it the other
typing rules just get pulled in I added
two two rules to type check my program
my multilanguage programs of course
they're relying on all the Machinery
that's underneath um that that already
existed so now what do we do what is
this lump embedding about this is the
interesting bit I have to decide what
happens I have to write down formal
semantics for how a value from one
language will get you know past how do
boundaries run basically so here's the
first one suppose that I have this value
form which is SM Tov right it's in my
value forms and it's sitting under an MS
boundary well that's just going to be
boundary cancellation right I gave ml a
uh um sorry I gave ml gave scheme a
value that's the
smv and scheme is giving it back to ml
so just cancel the boundaries and you
get the value right
um what if we have something under one
of these Ms boundaries right it's a
scheme value but it doesn't look like a
lumped value at all that's what that
side condition is saying it wasn't it's
not a lumped wrapped you know wrapped in
a lump kind of value well then that's an
error that should never happen Okay um
and finally we want to be able to cancel
out these lumps in the other direction
so how do we uh give a semantics for SM
boundaries that have an msv underneath
them right that's a value form as well
so you just cancel boundaries so really
the two interesting rules are the top
one and the bottom one and the middle
one is just an error case right that
should never happen okay nothing really
interesting happened in this semantic is
it's the lump embedding I'm just passing
lumps over wrapping something in a lump
boundary bringing it back and canceling
my my boundaries right okay um they I'm
going to move on to a second semantics
and then I'll show you that this is
actually a fairly powerful um semantics
nonetheless they show that in the paper
but I won't get into details so so let's
talk about designing a sort of take two
how can we do better than a lump
embedding which seems rather
uninteresting um so this lump embedding
model stable pointers in hasal so it's
not that it's not useful it actually is
a feature that exists in languages um
but we don't have to limit interrupt in
this way so that only lumps can flow
across the boundary what we can do
instead is something richer
um we can convert values at boundaries
so if something is a number in the red
language we can convert it to a number
in the to the uh corresponding number in
the blue language and we can similarly
do this do something for functions and
so on as well as we'll see in a second
so basically what we're going to do is
we're going to uh going to try to
convert values from one language to the
other so that they look like values of
the right shape or type okay so we're
going to call this they call this the
natural embedding
do the natural thing in terms of
converting okay so uh remember step 2A
was this decide on what kind of
interrupt you want to allow well this
time natural embedding is going to say
use the type annotation on a boundary to
guide how the value is converted from
one language to the other so I already
said this if something isn't has a natat
sitting on a b sorry has an has int
sitting on a boundary then just convert
the integer from one language to an
integer in the other language in this
case I'm just going to change the color
right okay all right I'm going to write
uh boundaries with a slightly different
set of letters I'm going to just add G
to to make it clear that I'm uh that
this is a different um semantics this is
the natural embedding but other than
that I want you to read Ms and uh smme
as just regular boundaries like there
were before ignore the G's in other
words they do something interesting
within the paper but I'm not going to
all right for this purpose we are not
going to add any new value forms because
we're not saying that the only values
that can flow across are lumped values
no all all values can kind of flow
across so what happens when a normal ml
value sits under an SM boundary well we
have to convert it to scheme so let's
take a look how do we do that
um so this is the first case which I was
uh which I've kind of alluded to twice
already um when I have a value um a
number in uh the I indicates int um and
I want to convert it from scheme to ml
well I'm just going to uh do that
conversion into number in the other
language I should have written this with
a uh blue n converted to a red n but
that's essentially the idea um and then
uh if I have um a value and I'm
converting it uh when you know the
boundary says that there should be an
integer there but it isn't actually an
integer you know it doesn't happen to be
a number then we report an error so
there's error checking going on at these
boundaries okay okay the most
interesting thing is functions how do
you convert a function in a blue
language into a function in a red
language right you're not going to go
walk over the entire function and
rewrite the code and that's not indeed
that you know they can't do that that's
not what they say we should do so here's
what we do if we have um this uh blue
Lambda in scheme and we want to convert
it into a red Lambda in ml um we we use
this standard trick from contracts uh in
racket for instance uh we basically take
that value uh we build a new red Lambda
an ml Lambda if you will that takes an
argument of the right type how do I know
what that type is well I had type tow
one arot to 2 sitting on the boundary so
I'm going to create a new function that
takes a tow one an ml tow one and inside
that function I'm going to say oh when
you give me some argument X I am going
to convert it so right here you give me
an argument X which is a to one I'm
going to convert it over to scheme and
and I'm then I'm going to pass it to the
scheme function uh scheme function is
going to give me back a scheme answer
and this boundary is going to convert
that answer from scheme to ml converting
it to a to to okay so take the input
convert it to scheme feed it to the
scheme function take the answer convert
it to ml that's how I built my wrapper
ENT around the original code to so that
I now have something that looks like an
ml function um and this is basically the
idea of higher order contracts um which
Robbie Findler has done a lot of work on
um okay and then let's do boundaries in
the other direction if we have an ml
number we just convert it to a scheme
number uh if the uh annotation on the
boundary matches and if we have an ml
function uh indicated by this red V uh
we just do the same wrapper trick again
this time we wrap it in a blue scheme
function and we convert the argument to
ml feed it to the function take the
result converted back to scheme just
opposite
direction okay so that's the natural
embedding that's the full semantics
that's in the paper for how you would do
something this like this called the
natural
embedding um there's there's other
things that the paper shows the paper
actually shows that the natural
embedding ends up being as expressive or
macro expressible in the lump embedding
but to me that's not the most
interesting part they I'll I'll mention
this other thing that's in the paper
which is um what about error
handling okay so suppose you have a
scheme with exception handling and it's
trying to interoperate with an either ml
or C where where you let's say C where
you have this convention that zero means
error right zero means some operation
has gone wrong let's say I want to
communicate that error that zero over to
the scheme side but this time I want to
raise an exception on the scheme side so
I want to let my zero error flow across
the boundary and tell scheme hey
exception something bad happened can go
handle it we can do that and the paper
talks about how to do that I won't go
into any details of that but um they
they sketch out a formal semantics for
that as well um the idea basically is
they they um instead of labeling your
boundaries with only types that flow
across enrich that type labeling and
introduce a new thing that's richer than
types which they call a conversion
strategy and this time you know
basically error numbers in C when there
you know you need to know when a number
in C uh could be indicating an error
right so what they do is they introduce
this new kind of conversion strategy
called int bang so
there's no int bang in ml right or orn C
but int bang the bang indicates that POS
that I might be expecting an error in
this condition so now you label these
boundaries with these richer conversion
strategies which are richer than types
um and basically what happens when
you're converting from C to scheme you
um and you see an INT bang you know that
if if you see a zero now you have to
convert it over to you have to throw an
exception on the scheme side to tell
scheme that it has something to handle
all right otherwise you just convert it
to the number number zero okay um and
vice versa when you convert from scheme
to C um when you uh if you're looking at
a scheme exception then you're going to
convert it over to a zero on the on the
cide to indicate to see that hey this is
an error so go handle it okay um
yeah all right so that's all I want to
do in terms of like formal semantics and
details of the paper but so far what
I've shown you is really kind of
you know if you can read the formal
semantics and you're used to typing
rules and you're used to writing down
operational semantics right what I what
I did was not a lot right in terms of
expressing interoperability it's
basically like writing down some formal
decisions but it opens up this vast
space of being able to think about those
decisions that's I think what the beauty
of this paper is is that it um you know
started to make so much new stuff
possible for people to think about and
reason through in terms of
interoperability decisions so so I want
to just talk briefly about some of the
work that came after some of the things
that were actually surprising and then
I'd like to end with a kind of a problem
that I think Still Remains open like we
still don't have you know great great
techniques or we we still don't have
full-fledged languages you know
practical languages for which we've
verified their foreign function
interfaces and proved that they're
actually type safe if they're two let's
say if they're two languages that are
both typed and they're interoperating we
design um these um ffis uh or language
interrupt mechanisms as a best effort
right with a nod to safety hoping that
every single decision that gets made and
every single conversion that's happening
and how it's implemented is actually
safe but we don't actually know so I'll
I'll kind of End by talking about how
maybe we could start to check some of
that stuff I do a lot of work in
compiler correctness and um verification
and stuff so techniques for how you
might be able to prove that actual
implementations are doing sound things
um is something that's uh that that I
care about and remain sort of an open
problem in some cases so I thought i'
just sort of put on a slide a flavor of
some of the things some of the papers
that have come since um you know
Matthews fendler since this
multilanguage semantics uh paper came
out and this is just a very very tiny
sampling um to kind of broadly cover the
space so one of the very first ones uh
was this paper that um you know just
took the mechanism and turned the crank
and they said okay I have a simply type
language and I have a dependently type
really rich dependently type language
dependently type languages are really
really complex right but they triy to
turn the crank and figure out how do we
do and trop at those boundaries between
simple type where we have to convert
something with a simple type to
something of a dependent type and vice
versa um and then um this uh this other
set of papers uh which is about uh
mixing two languages one which is has um
you know just copyable data unrestricted
data and another one which has an apine
type system which makes sure that any um
thing of apine uh type or you can think
linear types will be used at most once
um something like this uh you know how
do you so for instance rust has a sort
of apine uh type system right how would
you mix uh rust with something like o
camel um that is definitely there's a
there's a sort of resource that must be
used at most once type of thing right if
you have a borrow or an owned resource
on the rust side um of course I'm being
a little bit simplistic these these
papers tackle much simpler calcul than
rust the rust and no camel problem Still
Remains open no nobody has a good good
solution to that um I mean we have we we
have best guess efforts but uh no
verified ffi for them um another one
that's uh this is actually um work that
my group did um how do you define
interoperability between a high level
functional language let's say it's um ml
or you know doesn't have to be
functional uh it could be Java or uh
anything else um but a typed high level
uh language and something like assembly
you know we do this all the time we
sprinkle assembly into the middle of
code right but what is its meaning what
does it do when it sits there like
what's the interop actually doing it's
probably breaking a lot of things and we
just kind of Hope right so um so we
tried doing this we defined a multil
language called funel Fun is for
functional T is for typed Assembly
Language and what we did is uh we we
said the Assembly Language will be typed
so that we had some sense of like what
are the properties that are required on
the assembly code so that it could
actually sit under a boundary and we
could say ah yes this program I can type
check it it's safe the multilanguage
program is safe so that requires um
actually wandering into new territory
because Matthews and Findler very
clearly said hey our recipe works for
any language that has expressions and
when you run them they produce values
assembly doesn't quite have expressions
and when you run them they don't quite
produce values right so the first
question becomes what is this thing that
I can put under a boundary what shape
does it have well it's sort of a com you
can think of it as a component and a
component can be multiple basic blocks
but if that is what an expression is
multiple basic blocks how do you know
could be three basic blocks it could be
five basic blocks how do you know when
that expression is done running and has
a value for you to convert over to the
other
side it's like
huh so so that actually required some
thinking and some innovation and and
trying to figure out what would you do
in this particular case um and basically
what what we do is you have to come up
with some sort of a calling convention
which which seems obvious in hindsight
right you have to come up with a calling
convention that when your assembly basic
blocks are done running they're going to
put a value in some particular register
and we added a new instruction which
basically said okay time to bounce over
to the other side to the other language
take the value in that register and
convert it over to a value for the
functional language so it's a
essentially a calling convention
solution um then um the last bit is is
slightly um is is rather unexpected so I
kind of want to just explain what that
is about you about here um so there
multilanguage semantics ended up being
quite useful for defining compiler
correctness so there was all this work
on compiler verification let me just
sort of motivate that um oh sorry that
that should not have been there um I
added section later um so let's talk
about compiler correctness there's been
a lot of work um all I don't know many
of you may have heard of comert which is
a verified C compiler uh fully verified
something that the pl Community is very
proud of um but um until recently even
though there's been so much spectacular
work in uh compiler verification a lot
of it was only giving us uh correct
compilation guarantees assuming that you
compile a whole program right so if I a
whole Pro Source program PS and I
compile it to a whole program PT then my
compiler is correct but that doesn't
really capture reality because in
reality you almost never compile a whole
program whatever you compile will almost
always be linked with at least with like
some sort of low-level libraries runtime
stuff um and more generally you may be
compiling code from a very different
language and then trying to link you
know code that comes from the blue
language for which you're writing a
verified compiler with with code that
comes from the red language and they're
both being compiled to this purple
Target thing right and now they have to
be linked so there was no specification
of compiler correctness that handles
that picture um and this is an
interesting space where um you know uh
multilanguage semantics kind of came in
handy so let me explain how so the
question was if I'm compiling a piece of
a program es source source expression
into some Target uh component then how
do I express that they are equivalent
that they behave the same right we know
how to define behave the same when if if
the source and Target are whole programs
you just run them you look at the trait
of observations they're full programs so
you can run them these are partial
programs you can't run them without
linking them with other stuff that was
the problem right so how do we even run
them to say that they produce the same
behaviors or the same observations and
then how do we write down the compiler
correctness spec so in reality what we
need to do somehow is say if I take ET
this compiled code and I link it with
some other code arbitrary other ET Prime
um then what I really want to say is if
I run this combined program at the
bottom right each linked with ET Prime
then it will behave the same morally
speaking as my source component linked
with ET
Prime but that doesn't make any sense
you can't link source code Target code
and run it or give it an operational
semantics right that doesn't exist so
it's sort of like okay naively yes
that's what we want but how do we do it
um but that's where multilanguage
semantics came in handy you can actually
uh if if you can write down an
interoperability semantics between your
Source language s and your target
language t then you can actually give a
semantics to that linking at the top
right where the blue piece and the
purple piece are being linked together
and um so you can do that with these St
and TS boundaries if you start to Define
source Target
interoperability um so the solution
becomes oh yeah I can link with ET Prime
I just wrap it in a boundary first and I
have a semantics for how that runs then
you can say that the bottom part link uh
when you run the bottom uh whole program
then you get the same behavior as the
top hole program so that was kind of a
surprising thing um and you know that
that uh multilanguage semantics can be
used in the specification of compiler
correctness uh to allow this kind of
linking with arbitary code and still do
compiler
correctness okay um let me take a look
okay so I want to end with one last
thing like where are we now um I really
think that the beauty of this technique
has been its Simplicity and how you can
turn the crank and then once people turn
the crank they run into the new really
really interesting problems you know the
ones that um hadn't been tried before
pairs of languages language features
that hadn't been tried before and so on
um but I think that there's still
something kind of important left to
tackle so Matthew spindler's
multilanguage semantics is all about how
do we write down semantics at the source
level about how these you know two
Source languages interoperate and when
they run what what do we see right
what's the
behavior but in reality um how do we
Implement interop right we almost never
in I mean it's not implemented at the
source language so what we'd really like
to do is be able to connect um you know
multilanguage semantics techniques the
interrupt we Define at the source level
let's say between that blue and orange
language up there um how do we Implement
that well we implement it by compiling
the code down to some sort of Target
code and then writing glue code that
implements the conversions which are
really the boundaries of multilanguage
semantics right so this high High Lev
boundary semantics that I'm writing down
ultimately they're all implemented in
gluc code at the Target level so for
this particular picture how do we show
safe interop that question kind of
hasn't really been answered and it can't
be answered if we only continue to work
at the multilanguage semantic Source
level even though though that
multilanguage semantics is so critical
to understanding what's happening at the
source ultimately we'd like to go
further and actually say that we have
verified um
ffis um so we need a framework for like
design and verific ation of um you know
sound language interrupt as it's that's
connected to the implementation so we
need to take Matthew spinler
multilanguage Source level stuff and
connect it to gluc code stuff at the
bottom so I'm just going to quickly End
by showing you an approach a framework
for doing that um that that uh we've
been working out so I'm going to start
by saying that um you uh okay so I'm I'm
just writing boundaries differently here
all right I can take orange code put it
in a boundary and say what type it is in
in the other language and I can do the
same for my blue code um but I'm just
slightly going to generalize my typing
rules for you so you can see where I'm
going um so here I'm going to say that a
language designer who wants interrupt
between language A and B a fundamental
decision that they're making and I've
already said this but I want to say it
just more explicitly a fundamental
decision that they're making is which
orange types are convertible to which
blue types right in the lump embedding
we saw we didn't want to allow very many
in the second one we saw we we went much
further and then I showed you conversion
schemes you went further still right so
I'm just trying to capture that more
formally that there's a vast set of
decisions there to be made in terms of
which types in this language do I want
to even allow uh you know to converge to
the other language and what type would
they end up as in the other language
right some of them you might not want to
allow for performance reasons because
you can never implement it perform in a
performant way but you the language
designer should be deciding that so I'm
just going to say that the language
designer decides what these converti
what is convertible between the
languages and then we do follow Matthews
Spindler boundary trick all right so
make your decision about what is
convertible um then how do these things
get implemented well I'm writing this
abstractly you the language designer The
implementor Who implementing this ffi
would then have to go and write the glue
code the conversions I'm writing that as
C the glue code that converts your
particular set of orange types to the
corresponding blue types and vice versa
and then our task is how do we verify
that that gluc code is taking things
that behave like the orange type and
actually safely converting them to
things that will behave like the blue
type and vice versa right you need to
know that you implemented it right that
at the end of the day what you see is
going to be the right thing so um what
we what we do for that sorry um is is
this is this um building a model of what
a source type means in terms of Target
code so for every single type in your
blue language langage um write down a
semantic model now this is the hard part
semantic models are like things that I
do for my research so this is this is
like you know involved um but the basic
idea I want to communicate is you want
to be able to build a model which says
what Target terms actually behave like
you know uh this type says they should
behave like so if to is a function then
you know the shape of that Target term
will look something like a closure Etc
right um and basically what we're trying
to do is capture the Bas of the of the
IR or the target language which gives us
those well- behaved
types once you've done that you can use
this model to prove that your
conversions are safe okay and all you're
trying to do is prove the following
thing that for every single
convertibility rule that you wrote down
this particular blue type can be
converted to Orange and vice versa you
just need to show that if you have a tar
piece of Target code that belongs to the
blue type then after you apply your glue
code conversion to it it it behaves like
it uh belongs to the orange type and
vice versa so it just gives you a
framework in which you can actually go
do the the real verification work um and
then from that follows type soundus
which I'm not going to get into so if
you want to know more about this uh we
had a paper on it um last year um now I
just sort of want to say that this paper
has three case studies done on pairs of
idealized languages uh the most involved
of them is actually interesting the one
one of you know one language is is
garbage collected and the other one is
manually has manually managed memory so
it's not trivial it's uh it's you know
hard but nonetheless the techniques in
this paper are at the level of you know
like let's say the Matthews Spindler
paper from poo 7 where they're really
simple and idealized so there's a long
way to go in terms of taking even this
technique and applying it to you know
richer languages more practical
languages um much you know real Source
languages and real targets uh and
actually verifying real
ffis all right um
let me sort of wrap up by saying um just
a few few words on why I think this
paper was really amazing so when this
first came out I'm gonna I'm going to
tell you my story um in 2007 I was a
postdoc so I just finished uh my PhD and
uh you know anyway when this paper came
out I remember thinking this is so
simple why is this a big
deal and all these years later after
I've built so much stuff myself and I've
seen others build so much work on it um
here are my thoughts language
interoperability is a really really
really hard problem this paper came up
with something really simple like a
really simple beautiful technique that
seemed too simple certainly to me at the
time and I'm sure to a lot of other
people but normally it's those things
that are simple but General right that
people can use and reuse you know time
and again and they become enablers right
they became uh this paper has has become
an enabler for like studying languages
that are far more complicated than we
could ever have wrapped our heads around
if this I think if this technique hadn't
come around right because it just
simplifies it gives you some basic
framework within which to work so you
can get to the harder problems of
Designing and thinking about what you
want to allow in terms of interop um so
with that and work on language
interoperability it's one of our most
challenging and least studied problems I
think or formally speaking thank you
thank you
thank you for your talk um I'm curious
uh from a simplistic point of view are
there techniques where you take for
instance an integer in a a high level
language and go towards perhap C where
the ranges of the integers are more
specific to its types is it the case
that the integer would have to be then
subclassed into you know this will fit
in a bite or a long or or something else
like that or is it is there techniques
kind of to work out that kind of
difference in representation that kind
of includes like memory allocation and
such at the same time I wouldn't say
that there are existing techniques but
this is exactly the hard work of what
you know we have to kind of look at what
is the compiler doing what is the
representation and then in the formal
semantics we basically have to capture
that um so there's no simple answer to
that it's just that you know now you
know exactly at which point that
question kind of arises and and all the
different things that you have to figure
out there's other things like you know
when you have boundaries in both you
have boundaries in both directions in
these semantics when you're designing
interrupt do you want the kind of
interrupt where if I have a value and
like in your uh in your example right I
have an integer uh and I convert it to
something some low-level representation
and I have to worry about all sorts of
things maybe alignment and so on or
let's say I have a Boolean and I want to
convert it to an integer in a low-level
language do you want your interrupt
semantics to have the property that if
you convert forward and then back again
you get the same value that's actually a
design decision and you know sometimes
you just can't so it's unless you enrich
somehow and uh keep some state or extra
information because there might be
information loss in One Direction is
what I'm trying to say right so all of
these things kind of come to the
Forefront as you think about the formal
semantics and its properties thank you
one more over here yeah uh so can do you
think that the techniques um that have
been presented here and the extended
versions of these can also be applied
for integrating memory models between
different languages for example okel
recently has created its own memory
model which is somewhat different
compared to the usual C n C++ memory
model and so do you think those can be
made to cooperate in a way like using
these techniques okay I didn't catch
everything you said but basically you're
saying if if can we you do I think we
can use this and zishan correct me if if
I'm getting anywhere wrong um but can we
use this to do interoperability between
languages with different memory models
right in
essence yes I think we absolutely can in
fact I would say that funel the
functional language and assembly is
exact you know is is an instance of two
languages very different memory models
um and those instances are hard right
you have to like really think about how
am I converting data um in this language
that respects the this particular memory
model into Data in the other language
that's like where the research is and
the really cool research is and and I
will point this out about funel right so
we were doing funel because we were
interested in interal between a source
and a Target though it's more General
than that you know you can think of them
as two Source languages because we do
write embedded assembly um but
nonetheless at the time I was struck by
the fact that um people who were doing
compiler verification for comert in
comert every single IR in the comert
compiler uses the same exact memory
model so their problem is way simpler if
they started to do interrupt between the
IRS and we were like oh no now if you
compile a higher level language to a
low-level language you're going to have
to address this problem so I think the
solutions
definitely I believe they have to exist
we just have to do the work to like
discover them in in all of the hard
cases that's you know lots of research
challenges but we've done it for
one uh the whole time you were talking I
was imagining that the punch line was
going to be that you're doing work in
this direction for web assembly with the
way web assembly is being touted as an
like interoperable holy gra in a sense
are you aware of any ongoing work to
apply this to like wi components for
example we are actually doing work in
some my group is um so uh right now what
um so some of it is active some of it is
you know intended like we will get to it
um but basically I'd like to use this
particular technique um you know that I
mentioned at the end um how do you
compile something like o camel to wasm
or let's say an idealized ml to start
with to uh to wasm and uh compile rust
to wasm I'd like to study stfe inop
between o camel and rust using that as a
vehicle okay sweet thank you we're also
designing something called Rich web
assembly which is a richer type system
on top and that might help Rich
wasm awesome thank you all and you're
here for couple days
[Applause]
right